if you love Westworld giddyup because
here are five other shows totally worth
checking out on this week's binge guide
hey guys Mads here coming at you from my
couch and Wes world is back with its
third straight certified fresh' season
and you guys are loving it so based on
what you're watching now here's where
you can watch next first on this list is
the BBC America sci-fi show orphan black
starring Tatiana maslany as an orphan
caught up in a deadly conspiracy after
learning that she's a clone this show
will appeal to your Westworld loving
senses with all sorts of unexpected
twists and turns the critics have said
that orphan black is a wild
science-fiction ride that incorporates
dramatic sensibilities which can turn
from suspenseful to light at a moment's
notice
binging this alone will take you just a
short 38 hours of your time and it's
available to stream in plenty of places
so enjoy another one you might like is
the AMC show humans about a suburban
family who buys the latest tech gadget a
robot serving this British show that's
based on a successful Swedish series
takes place in a parallel present learn
the lines between human and machine much
like Westworld
critics call humans a mature high-octane
thriller offering emotional intrigue and
thought-provoking suspense and with
three fresh seasons that only have eight
episodes each this one's a pretty easy
binge especially if your robot servant
takes care of all your toys next if
you're in love with the pure sci-fi and
futuristic elements of West's world be
sure to check out amazon's the expanse
the expanse is set in a future where
humanity is colonize the solar system
and fans can't get enough considering
the campaign to save the show after it
was cancelled by sci-fi channel critics
like the expanse because it blends
sci-fi elements and detective Noir into
a visually compelling whole but all four
seasons of the show are fresh with the
new one coming later this year so get to
Benton but if you're all about Westworld
season one and that classic western
field the HBO classic Deadwood is your
present under the tree right now
and after three certified fresh' seasons
Deadwood ended somewhat prematurely only
to be given a sort of proper send-off
with last year's Deadwood the movie
critics have said that Deadwood offers a
richly textured portrait of an Old West
community buoyed by its talented
ensemble cast and with three seasons in
one movie this is well worth your time
and finally if you loved West world but
felt it was a little too tame you dare w
you should really check out the Netflix
anthology series love death and robots
this collection of animated shorts has
the gore that Westworld fans will love
and the sexes and spans various genres
like sci-fi fantasy horror and of course
comedy critics say that love death and
robots has enough creative death to
satisfy cyberpunk aficionados who love
their robots to have some heavy metal
influence and it's only gonna take about
four and a half hours to watch season
one so you really have no excuse alright
guys hopefully this will help guide you
through your next to binge sessions be
sure to check back for more
recommendations based on other shows
that you love right here on the couch
tomato's bench guys see you next time
[Music]
you